is my next review gonna be a review of
the movie Dredd yes it is are we gonna
talk about The Hobbit right now yeah we
are where's our the new trailer to Peter
Jackson's The Hobbit an unexpected
journey has finally come out I found it
weird that it took this long to come out
hey good things are worth waiting for ha
to the east over ranges and rivers lies
a single solitary people the dwarves are
determined to reclaim that and
immediately in this trailer you feel
like you're back in middle-earth and the
best part about this trailer is Martin
Freeman as Bilbo Baggins I already knew
the dudes a good actor from Sherlock he
kills it as Watson but there's a moment
in this trailer where I was like that's
Bilbo Baggins this chance - how is that
not awesome as much faith as I have in
the director and the actor it's really
cool to see a moment in this trailer
where you're like that could not be more
Bilbo Baggins and in this trailer you
have that sweet cinematography that you
came to know and love and Lord of the
Rings it's back in The Hobbit it's
really cool to see that and one thing
this trailer comes my mind on also are
the dwarves it'll be really important to
love and connect with these dwarves I
would take each and every one of these
dwarves over the mightiest army
in this trailer I'm like yeah I'm
probably gonna love these dwarves
especially that one that seems to have a
bit of an attitude problem if there is
the funny dwarf I'll probably like him
most but this one's gonna be the badass
loyalty scene where he stands up short
again that is mr. badass right there or
put something of badassery one dude I'm
curious about it's not one guy that was
on Santa's sleigh in the woods who is
that dude I've narrowed it down to two
possibilities life is gonna be none of
them someone's gonna be like I mean it's
Silmarillion page 54 paragraph 3 line 2
they mentioned that one guy I know that
because I know everything about The
Silmarillion because I'm crazy god bless
you crazy people who would know that but
I think he's either Tom Bombadil or
radagast the brown I don't know which
one I haven't been on IMDB or anything
like that but hey that's why God
invented comment sections on YouTube
videos what were you thinking is comment
below I want to know your theory look on
IMDB though just be legit about it if it
is radagast the brown it would make
sense that he'd be a little middle-earth
hippy right in Santa's sleigh in the
woods and there are a couple of really
cool character moments like when
Galadriel asked Gandalf she's like why
the halfling
Gandalf replies eyed Bilbo Baggins just
because I'm afraid
humanizing moments from Gandalf the gray
that right there was the moment where I
was like I'm gonna watch this trailer
10,000 times today and on the hit 9000
368 a busy man
and if you want to see some a Martin
Freeman's superb timing and delivery
with his lines it's when he's talking to
go on the Hobbit an unexpected journey
just looks like it's going to have what
we loved about Lord of the Rings without
being a Lord of the Rings rip off you
know you can't clone Lord of the Rings
it's not the same as Lord of the Rings
but it'll have that good dialogue great
camerawork great characters I mean now
we're in September and you start
thinking alright what's my favorite
movie of the years the Dark Knight Rises
is it Avengers the new Hobbit trailer
just lands now and it's like hey the
year ain't over yet you tuber I'm like I
know I know it's not you're cooler than
me
I have a feeling that any Lord of the
Rings fan who has bitched about The
Hobbit being a trilogy will be glad The
Hobbit is a trilogy and they will like
the trilogy it just is a theory of mine
we'll see how it goes alright so the new
trailer - The Hobbit and unexpected
journey have you seen it what have you
thought about it series - no of course
so comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]